one thing I forgot to mention during the
show a lot of people have asked me where
they can get completely normal now that
it's not on Netflix region it's not on
netflix is because the license expired
I had like a five year license or
something like that anyways I got I had
it restocked so it's in my store I
signed a bunch of them if anybody wants
one it's there along with a whole bunch
of other merch so we have you can go
through my site Tom Segura com go to the
store or you can go directly to merch
method comm slash Tom Segura alright
thanks guys
your butthole got it you got that in
there oh yeah
Jude or titties is coming up right
that's right Tom I'm so excited to do
the Gotham comedy club and Jude or
titties this weekend may 19th and 20th
and then June 1st through 3rd Denver
Colorado the Denver come on yeah works
in the downtown location June 16th and
17th man-friend disco at the punchline
and then June 22nd flappers comedy club
I run my hour for the last time before I
shoot it and I'm about to reveal very
soon when do you reveal it should be
soon ok and that's it those are my dates
guys wonderful thousand ranch calm
that's right here's where I'm going next
Tucson Arizona the Rialto Theatre then
Reno Nevada then the Pechanga casino in
Temecula and then I am in a dirty down
south I'm in brick Minh Virginia I'm in
vagina Beach Virginia
again I'm in jeans borough North
Carolina Asheville North Carolina and
Charles has come South Carolina
those are are my southern dates
I added Montreal I'm doing just for
laughs one show only at Olympia on July
then I had to Hampton Beach Wilmington
Delaware Baltimore balls and [ __ ] and
then I'm off to mom Australia the first
week in June I will also announce my
fall dates and it's a lot of cities that
I haven't hit this year many of the
cities that people hit me up about I'm
probably coming to your city and I'll
announce that in a few weeks we are
doing the podcast live right now we are
signed up for two in Irvine we're going
to do July 9th and October 8th we had to
find dates that we weren't touring and
everything and those are two of them so
those are also on sale and also August
23rd in West Palm Beach Florida at the
improv come see your mom's house live
it's really fun to see a live version of
it and that's all at Tom Segura comm
slash tour there you go great oh gee
guys if you do your shopping on Amazon
please remember to shop through our
website go to your mom's house podcast
comm click on the banner at the bottom
of the home page do your shopping as you
normally would and now we have the UK
Canada and you're not safe America so do
your shopping there also this episode of
your mom's house is brought to you by me
undies
am i wearing a pair of my undies now
right this second yeah because I wear
them everyday because they became our
the sponsor of our show and I got
addicted and I have all of them
I do the boy briefs I do the cheeky
briefs I have so I have all the designs
and I can't tell you that now I won't
even buy underwear that is not me and
these I'm not as the absolute
honest-to-god truth I just love it
because it's special I mean if you've
been settling for store-bought underwear
like those disgusting five packs I mean
I have something that will change your
life for the better and it
is me undies me IDs are designed in LA
and made from sustainably sourced micro
Modell of fabric three times softer than
cotton it's designed in LA and you know
me Tom if it's not la it's garbage
oh it's a West Coast only char only LA
specifically me Andy's solder than soft
luxe undies common and ever-changing
selection of classic colors bold shades
and adventurous patterns so you can
tailor your undies to your own personal
style and guess what you can save time
and money each month with a monthly
subscription and if you're not ready for
a subscription that's okay you can still
you can still save [ __ ] he's so excited
right now she really wants to save that
money times because me onions may undies
is offering you 20% off your first pair
just use our special URL the undies
dot-com slash mom and get 20% off your
first pair so go ahead URI vamp your
underwear drawer you deserve it
one thing where she wants it nice again
I wish they made a dog underwear yeah
that's why she's barking cuz I'm going
my pair she's like why don't I get that
underwear once again that's me Andy calm
slash mom me Andy calm slash mom they
say laughter is the best medicine if
that's the case and see so is the best
medical insurance you've ever bought
streaming service that provides complete
coverage for stand-up television and
original content you'll never need to
worry about that weird thing growing on
your you know well you know never to
worry about that again see so you get
unlimited access to see so original
series next day late night hilarious
stand-up specials binge worthy classics
including 42 seasons
Saturday Night Live entire Monty Python
catalog and more both seasons of hidden
America with Jonah ray check the debut
TV series from my brother my brother and
need the McElroy brothers McElroy isn't
it
McElroy brothers Mac
or an animated fantasy role-playing game
starring Dan Harmon hilarious famous
comedians to see so has that as well see
so is a new home for all your favorite
comedy bred comm stand-up specials bin
jabal classics and more like British
comedies like the IT Crowd and Monty
Python or maybe prefer classics like
kids in the hall Parks and Rec it's all
there man
it's all there the day after late night
TV airs it's up there access to so
content from anywhere at any time using
iOS Android Roku Amazon fire Apple TV
Windows or Xbox one and here we go see
so is just 399 per month no joke 399 per
month for all the comedy you want
anytime anywhere at free just go to se
ESO calm right now to sign up for one
month free with promo code mom at
checkout that's C so calm se ESO calm
promo code mom C SOCOM promo code mom
jeans Tom do you know who is the number
one fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country yes who is it
blue apron you got it blue apron we use
it we love it it's fantastic to help
stay together as a family
yeah in other words we cook these meals
together and they're so affordable for
less than $10 per person per meal blue
apron delivers seasonal recipes along
with pre-portion ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals I love the
variety of blue apron I'm telling you I
can only cook about four things but with
blue apron they don't repeat the recipes
within one year so you can make all
kinds of wonderful discoveries it's
flexible if you travel if you just
decide you don't want this week's
delivery you don't need to get it don't
get it and it's so easy each meal comes
with step-by-step easy-to-follow recipe
with a recipe card and pre-portioned
ingredients and can be prepared in 40
minutes or less trust me if you think
you don't know how to cook you can with
blue apron it's so
explicit and everything comes already
measured so you don't have to think
that's the best part about it and it's
guaranteed blue aprons freshness
guarantee promises that every ingredient
in your delivery arrives ready to cook
or they'll make it right check out this
week's menu and get your first three
meals for free with free shipping by
going to blue apron comm slash mom now
here's what's on the menu this month
Tommy you ready through it remember
we've had this one already beef teriyaki
stir-fry with sugar snap peas and lime
rice I was pretty amazed we didn't do
the rice because we are Kido and paleo
prime of sorry baked spinach and eggs
flatbread with sauteed asparagus and
lemon aioli 3 cheese and baby broccoli
Stromboli with tomato and oregano
dipping sauce I mean why would you ever
make this stuff on your own crazy
crispy Salman and roasted potato salad
with pickled mustard seeds and clam
fresh sauce so give it a whirl you're
going to love how good it feels
and taste to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so
don't wait that's blue apron calm slash
mom blue apron a better way to cook
there you go that's it guys thank you to
our sponsors thank you for listening
this is a really awesome show today we
have we have some regular show stuff and
then we have our first guest in studio
ever in this studio and for that matter
in a long time and it's probably not the
guest you expected thank guarantee
you're going to enjoy it we got the real
water champ here go ah maybe Divas
Champion Oh
enjoy all right Jean we're back
oh we're recording now we're recording
yeah it's exciting yeah like you're sure
you're very fancy today yeah well you
you usually dress like a slob and so I'm
dressed like a slob hoping that you'd be
dressed like a slob why did you say that
I don't know sorry but you've got a nice
shirt on and now I feel like I look like
a dick and you're gone I
I feel like you always will you dick me
yeah really but I'm trying to match your
low level of attire that's not really
dressed up for ya I was just remembering
one time you did it we did this episode
and you were wearing your underwear and
we're on recording video yeah but you
couldn't idiot honor you
yeah but I could see it I bet anchors do
that you know on TV I think they do I
think I'm seeing something more guy
stood up and it was like denim wearing
shorts or something yeah yeah no shoes
no shoes farts they don't care it's a
desk show did the death cares and we
going to do dates at the top
we already did them babe oh we did yeah
sorry yeah I like when you get mad at me
like cut stupid no it's a good question
when I hear you we redid it babe thank
you I really you're gonna hit me or
guide me how much do you hate me in my
fantasies how much you hate me when I
[ __ ] famous when I get something wrong
leg cut what does it do to you it upsets
Hannah
[ __ ] just at my core yeah yeah yeah
why there's such a dumb question because
it was it was a silly question as dumb
dumb yeah stupid and then in your head
do you are you like so stupid [ __ ]
yours I just my you know that's your
internal yeah you always kind of make up
insult different I do I always assumed
when I upset you that you're like stupid
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] I never say that and
you want to use like that but what are
you saying it has to be some variant of
that guys she's so stupid I'm single
wish I was on tinder does it go there no
it's not it's not that it's not that
that's just you know I wonder how much
longer she'll is like that yeah like do
you fantasize about the second wife for
just being single second third and home
would you remarry no no why go through
this again I won't do this again would
you have a second family that's the
craziest part when people do that yeah I
would you have more babies with another
woman I mean another state so they don't
like run into each other yeah and then
when you're on you're like I'm really
not one of them right do you tell her I
think you found no one
you're like I'm going up no idea right
I'm going to Denver again yeah well you
have us oh yeah you have to open up that
second company in Denver and you're
always in Denver every other every other
weekend or maybe you become a truck
driver
that's kind of the easiest way to driver
yeah until that trucking companies like
you got a new route you got to go every
week to San Francisco and you're like oh
then you start a third family I guess
yeah you got to be real tight with money
oh my gosh to families to support and
then if you get up to three that's
bananas
yeah that's too hard not with it and
then always like Daniel you travel that
guy no yeah and that's how it goes I
know well let's start the show
okay let's do it then let's go ready
yeah and keep go attention of the water
detection in the water this is the
Orange County Sheriff's Department
be advised State Parks is asking us to
make an announcement to let you know you
are paddleboarding next to approximately
15 great white sharks there advising
that you exit the water in a calm manner
both sir the sharks are as close as the
surf line oh thank you for your
cooperation
yes who is Randy don't bring anyone love
into this well welcome welcome to your
mom's house with Tom Segura
I'm Krystina position
yeah
[Music]
so ridicu
you're turning into such an angry dad
what's so funny like this morning Ellis
was flashing water outside the sink
because he plays in the sink and then he
likes to do this thing where he splash
it upside because then we get mad and
then we pull him out like it's a game we
all play now and he spilled water like
he does every time the nearly god damnit
Ellis get dammit would I tell you about
the water scare him I was like oh that's
such a dad mode I'm going to full dad
mode on him well yeah I mean he was
spilling a lot of water all right come
on goddamn it
I have a feeling I'm gonna be a lot of
goddammit oh the kids gonna hear that
all the time
yeah yeah so dads do though they show
their rage I'm going to be angry someone
where do you get a lot of pent-up anger
and then it comes out yeah it's that
little things like this alright I guess
it's all like for you but then it comes
out to other thing I figured I figure
like you don't want to you don't want to
confront whatever annoys you in the
moment and then it stores other stores
other doors up and then you get mad at
the kids spilling water right or like
Christina forgot that we did the dates
already oh
so angry yeah yeah um this is terrifying
we saw this clip and I I've swam in
those waters I think I learned the
service along the waters yeah and the
crazy the Orange County part mellow my
guy matter you're paddleboarding out
there now they fly over first you notice
I'm hovering other hovering to be
somebody's in trouble out here and then
they go hey you don't be alarmed
they're just coming on down yeah great
white sharks yeah calmly take yourself
to the to the shore how did that guy
even contain his emotions enough to be
back home
the guy
yeah I kind of laughed I thought at one
point he's like uh you're a little
there's a little pitch change where he
said calm family and it sounds like he's
almost laughing because he knows oh my
God look at the [ __ ] size of that
fifteen of them dude attention on the
water attention in the water this is the
Orange County Sheriff's Department
be advised State Parks is asking us to
make an announcement to let you know you
a paddle boarding next to approximately
fifteen great white sharks only they're
advising that you exit the water right
here listen in a calm manner you know
reading interest rates are as close as
the surf line oh thank you for your
cooperation
man if I heard that [ __ ] and watch the
water yeah I have to be paddling fast as
well you not know is heavily populated
out great white sharks like some of
which which are these surf line please
divide into the water how many horses
are out to make additional announcements
[ __ ] me how about you guys drop a line
down and pluck that person out of the
water look you're in the [ __ ] they do
that that's how they rescue people
drowning or far out you they just drop a
line down and then the lifeguard jumps
out and gets you out I know I'd say
let's do that instead of the
announcement over and over well it was a
little more complicated size of action
no I
when I was on road rules I didn't know
no I know I trained I was a Coast Guard
and I trained I trained with the
Australian coast guard I did a Bondi
Beach and they taught us how to do that
that was one of the missions how you get
lowered by the rope and then you pluck
the person out so what's your theory on
why they didn't do that I don't know
laziness you think they're just being
lazy yeah I think they wanted a cool
video to submit to you to get those hits
those views I I don't know you know
that's not true I know who knows you
know so true pitchaiah
that'll be terrifying though oh my god
great white mics whites right there -
yeah [ __ ] man [ __ ] it's nuts there's a
lot of them go ahead that's there's got
to be nothing [ __ ] scarier I mean I
think if I heard that
son-in-law I guess soon as he [ __ ]
started that announcement the first
moment attention on the water in the
water this is the arch County Sheriff's
Department when bidden State Parks is
asking us to make it announcement to
liquor you a paddle boarding next to
approximately 15 green white New York's
ranks are dare advising that you exit
the water in a calm manner and then just
pull the diarrhea comes what coming out
the back of my shorts no do you think
that would attract the Sharks to lobby
or repeal repeal know the [ __ ] there'd
be a new it's just a new taste and smell
them and they don't [ __ ] okay yeah
that's what you eat it's all ground up
in an out burger and what whatever trash
you've been eating on the road I didn't
trash although I did have horrible meals
in Eugene yeah I heard that's what I'm
saying yeah sickle cell and I went up to
Eugene and back to Portland Oregon again
and Portland shows were really fun man
we could not get a good meal it's so
weird I hate that we went to Eugene we
went I don't want to trash the places
you know because it's like it's they
weren't like egregiously trying to ruin
ours time yeah it just wasn't good we
went to a place for the lingerie this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] what did you order
well he had a head of shrimp rock band
ah there was salad shrimp ah the ones
that are naughty I would say one quarter
of one inch you know those yams yeah and
then order some oysters for us the glass
jeez
hey where did you guys go with that I
want to stay in place no it's a nice if
they're there like it's a good
restaurant it was [ __ ] terrible then
we want to I forget another place after
show is all right and then we breakfast
the next morning tells indigestion
now [ __ ] up breakfast is hard it
sucks
yeah then we went to Portland and we did
have something good you know you can
always get something good in Portland
Oregon parlons amazed for us there we go
we go so it's meat rattle such good food
and meat rattle - yeah really does this
is our first good meal was important
terrible there's nothing worse than bad
road
food because then with the road food
comes the road [ __ ] oh so the [ __ ]
hurts
everything's hungry you're miserable
tired but but thanks everybody that came
out that's create the end up doing four
shows a revolution all great yeah it's
amazing
thank you very odd jeans there I wanted
to point out that um you and Ryan are
both in a special category now yeah you
both no longer buying regular people
shoes no I since I had a child my back's
messed up my feet messed up I have
sciatica and I started to wear
orthopedic shoes yeah now not all of
them look good there's a brand called
vionic that I've been into and they make
really good looking orthopedic shoes
yeah and then this is an unpaid sponsor
yes yeah it is yeah the real thing
because if you if you have sciatica of
like spinal misalignments or whatever I
have one leg shorter than the other it's
but now that I whole life but for some
reasons if I had a kid my hips got all
messed up and everything so it's gotten
bad ears with it yeah sickle-cell worthy
I have the same ones but slip on the
fish's edge is the single dad our
support sevens Oh again New Balance he
said they come in four colors only yeah
it's like these all maroon yeah I think
beige and one other but he said they
completely changed the way his back
example you have to because I'll women's
shoes are horribly unsupportive if not
damaging to our feet the ballet flat
users wouldn't even do any balances by
the way yeah I have those I have those
exact except slip-on from when I was
preggers yeah it's terrible
yes you know that mr. Hanson's are my
new ones yeah those look for doing that
to some people really like them and some
people [ __ ] hated them I couldn't
believe how many people everyone's an
[ __ ]
are those for bicycling no no that's our
bicycle they're not are they for running
our specific sport no no they're just
total like what do they call you know
social shoes like they're just walk
around shoes they're not for street wear
okay yeah but a man they got a lot of
people like
I'm just it's a terrible the dem shits
is doodoo someone called these dad shoes
these are like yeah the super exclusive
undefeated collabo the Diaz Noah dad
shoot me well can I tell you there's a
fine line between cool sneakers and then
too much going on yeah to make them look
supportive and then that's where it goes
into a dad sneaker yeah so I think why
they're say not this is just my theory
yeah is when you got a lot of different
hooks and things injure it when it
starts to look like a hiking shoe or a
bicycle shoe what out of it that way it
loses its cool yeah see I still think
there I think this is a bunch of nerds
on my [ __ ] Instagram yeah I have no
style whatsoever I don't know I kind of
agree with I'm sorry I think those are a
little dad support yeah really yeah I
don't know I think yeah I think there's
a bunch of tools I'm going to put a
picture of my shoes my new orthopedics
and we'll see who like who they like
better I'm clearly the shoe champ you
did send it you did send in those send
back those terrible ones right well
because I ordered them and I got four
pairs and I tried them on for you
because look I let's keep it real you're
the one that looks at me all the times I
want to look decent
yeah so you okayed two of them and then
to you were like no yeah did I have sit
down - I thought I said sorry we shut
down one pair the other one didn't
they're too big yeah they were a hot
pink slip on sneaks yeah like a strap
like a mary-jane strap on top and you
did not like that look well what about
that you were you not in which we had a
photo of them so we could really break
it down you can google it vionic
slip-ons
hot pink c VI o ni c bionic slip on
women's sneaker pink hot pink
try that one okay now they also make a
cool ass lavon's I got a gray pair like
suede looking those are dope and then
I'm wearing
yeah those are them yeah those are them
does it see I just don't feel like they
were that bad
so whack these are like what you know
this reminds me of huh
I'm somewhere in Europe and then some 78
year old American woman is on I was with
a tour group uh-huh she's like I haven't
been back here in 50 years and walks
around the corner wearing these I'm like
oh that's nice old lady sneakers you got
on yeah because she's like I didn't have
them I just collapse to the ground in
pain is she wearing khaki culottes yeah
yeah not either terrible I thought those
were cute now try the blue color do you
like the blue ones better is it not a
color thing oh it's not a color it's the
style yeah a kiss [ __ ] old lady style
yeah but I need sneakers that are have
art to have art story we've got to keep
hunting right now I have I have the New
Balance ones they're identical to what
sickle cell wears a guy named Jojo those
are terrible
you should see him when he had jeans on
so we got to get him some bionics I know
I'm telling you it's all about that arch
support yeah because my feet will hurt
if I just wear regular flats yeah can't
do it yeah forget it it's crazy
it's part of Aging you know I know so
your feet will hurt my feet will hurt
major back my tack sciatica it all
flares up it's really bad yeah it's the
fun of being 40 yeah so we also went on
a mommy's night out a TM n total mom
night we spent the night in a hotel like
we do once a month yo and we ate a lot
of bad food don't tell our trainer no
don't tell her and we also relax in bed
we watched a shitty movie didn't we
watch me stupid yeah was it started that
um what's that great actor he was on
Breaking Bad young kid oh yeah I like
that I don't know his name
no no Blake some Blake Lively plague
Lively the guy from Breaking Bad and it
was a cool premise but it just went to
[ __ ] so many movies just go to [ __ ] man
to just [ __ ] the [ __ ] bed and this
one did too the premise was that his
girlfriend just disappeared like they're
together for four years and then one day
she disappears so
happens to her and then he starts
looking for and you're not going to like
all the answers you get that kind of
thing so you start you get involved and
get invested yeah
but the reveals are are just stupid
yeah the end was kind of lame super lame
yeah super lie also you know what
disappointed is not I mean you can say
that this is a sexist I guess but I
don't buy her being what they said she
was in other words not that I don't
believe any woman could do that
I don't believe that actress is that
yeah
you understand I'm saying and if some
you're saying like she's not it's not
believe he wasn't tough enough in a
weird she wasn't come on she was just
like a cube lon she wasn't like a tough
tough blonde I mean yeah it is
completely unbelievable no what about a
look I've got a lady doctor do you buy
that it depends yeah where's she from
right what about a lady scientist is
that totally ridiculous - yeah like a
not attractive one sure like a Grey's
Anatomy what's her name the blonde
actress Ann Heigl Katherine Heigl like
Dubai scientists that she was a doctor
no course not
no no what should she be 225 to 240 what
large is everything now why should she
be occupation wise would Katherine Heigl
that you'd believe that she what she
does for a living in a movie I'm saying
oh um drinker yes oh no that's
disgusting real estate real estate yeah
secretary secretary yeah that's not for
hot chicks anymore oh that's on my 50
flight attendant yeah yeah mate agent
gate agent at the airport no what could
she be I mean I'm I'm of the school of
thought that she could be a scientist a
doctor or a lawyer she's active okay
yeah okay so your theory that attractive
people don't go into professions either
gender really that's not true we have
attractive people that we professionally
deal with
mmm don't goes into trouble now okay no
we don't okay we have really good
looking professionals that we deal with
now come on now okay you know that's not
true I mean I'm not saying there's not
any out there but that's a most part you
know uglier people have to strive to
make a name for themselves they have to
work in life so I feel like you usually
see uglier looking people let's move on
let's go on to other posit but I'm
totally right about that I don't know
now I do know it's not like a it's not
like you don't see supermodels at the
hospital no you don't see many
supermodel doctors that's true
now why forget to get a bunch of emails
from people who are like I was a model
and now I'm a scientist I can assure
send pictures okay right okay I bet
you're a borderline model marginally
attractive our plus-size model Pig yeah
yeah with your big old dirty [ __ ]
[ __ ] hanging down donkey - it's like oh
speaking of movies yeah so we also were
trying to keep the family tradition
going in our our NIDA way of ordering an
adult film right oh well let's just to
say it's a tradition that started we
didn't start the fire but it started on
us and the Dominican Republic when we
stayed at a resort that played hardcore
pornography on our television and it was
like wow does everybody get this in
their room now
now could we ask it was just us and we
watch a lot of hardcore stuff that week
and Dr yeah and then I got us two kind
of getting used to that now it's hard to
go back that's true it's like eating at
five-star restaurant and then you know
you can't go to McDonald's every day
after that so now when we stay in a
hotel or go into vacation we like to
order it on TV that D our place it was
around the clock non-stop I was in a
hotel in Europe once where it was like
that too and somewhere where it was like
24/7 you get hard-core pornography yeah
and in this place it was obviously you
order
movie right or you can order like the
for our package and all that stuff for
hours and so fine it's a thing about
would be our is that like your kid could
just turn the channel and find that I
wasn't on restricted times you know was
channel fixing on right okay hi which is
kind of cool because then you can
explain to things your kid at once sure
there's sixty-nining yeah and this is
hardcore porn but this was a miss out
babies are made
yeah we uh we look to the titles that
was not one of them yeah no but we were
trying to figure out like wow is
possible snort cheese yeah I'm trying to
figure out what's the what's the one we
went a lot what's your theme for the
night gonna be yeah I mean you know a
lot to choose from there's a lot of milf
stuff is very popular very popular we
also found that a new genre not new but
a genre yeah become they had multiple
films prevalent and that was hairy mmm
hands are seeing four or five titles in
a hotel right it's a trend yeah it's
picked up it was like my hairy teen and
my wife's hairy bush their hair oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting on my
theory on the hairy stuff is that that
place probably accommodates what's
popular by the client for the clientele
yeah so either it's like maybe they have
a lot of Asian businessmen who are into
hairy stuff maybe it's Europeans who
come over and like hairy stuff why those
two what do you categorize those well I
know that the Asians are very they're
into specific kinky stuff yeah they like
you know there are vending machines that
sell dirty panties in Japan the
schoolgirl thing I know yeah so they
have particular kinks nationally I'm
sure we do - I just don't know them I
don't know like what are we like I think
we're obsessed with Mother's milf knows
which is really popular which is just
code for over 30 like it's not a sterile
world right it doesn't mean you're a mom
it just means you're over you know team
yeah it's either keen or milf it's super
weird so
I'm going to go with Asian the Asians
because they are generally hair less or
less hairy than white people so I'm
thinking they that might be the new king
I don't know what do you was here who's
buying me hairy stuff I see I think it's
less specific to them specifically as
much as it is just that's where the
trend is period across the song really I
think so yeah so you're saying that
that's just the genre are all over the
world I mean maybe not all over the
world but I'm saying that overall I
think that John was probably just
popular at the moment sure you know it's
exciting news for me are you know just
one time to breast feed you this crisis
I feel these sickness so crazy right now
you suck me dry
okay look here are you thirsty nothing
come on another job okay would you
rather impromptu you who would you
rather feast on this guy's big nips oh
oh
or you're doing Cup play with your new
friends it's not sexual you're just
wearing the costumes I got had to wear a
costume really yeah I opened my eyes
water well part of that would it be Oh
wasn't for you I wouldn't like him
talking about it all the time oh my god
and I remember him big hang like dick
yeah like what is like body dysmorphic
nipples yeah they're not you know yeah
he clearly played with them a lot or
stretched him but he [ __ ] them up yeah
so he can make videos like this what a
noble cause to destroy your nipples so
that you can make videos for other
perverts to look at oh god yeah so okay
so we had the titles there was Harry but
then there was yeah the one that really
caught our attention really caught our
attention I'm really disappointed didn't
watch it though can I say that can I
tell the title sure it was [ __ ] my
Triple D [ __ ] wife Yeah right I was like
this is perfect
Billie I got one right here going next
to me yeah what I thought you were doing
movies behind my back yeah well you know
of course you know what I really like
about that is that it incorporates two
genres there's the big boobs yeah and
also the cuckolding thing of like
humiliate me by [ __ ] my wife and i'm
leway Triple D another popular genre
yeah that's a big one yeah yeah well I
just googled that um that title and I
found some other ones I found I let him
[ __ ] my [ __ ] wife please bang my wife
she double D [ __ ] me yeah friend [ __ ]
my wife and comes in her
what I like about these titles is
there's no mystery there's no no
metaphor no there's no veiling what
what's happening here yeah kind of nice
I know what your mom what wife
it's just nothing is it maybe bang my
time I might be banging my Triple D [ __ ]
white really yeah F might be too harsh
can I please turn the air up I'm
freezing oh it's fun it's distracting my
legs are freezing my white wife is used
by three black cloud no what are you
doing man I'm so cold
no sweatshirt on it my I have my I have
socks on oh come on man you're ruin
everything you ruin everything
what are you raising it to what you put
it on we have heat lamps in here man
coal I can't even see jeez you seriously
ruin this how did I ruin and just did
right now it's fine you don't even feel
it wonder I'm going to lower it if it
gets too hot we'll just turn the air on
that's all I need your balls milked
you're so aggressive today so anyways
ggressive we didn't order that film it
also brought me back to the time we went
on a cruise with my parents yeah whole
family actually and we decided we want
to order a movie then and he did yeah
and on this cruise you could order a
film yeah and it was a softcore film
yeah I was so disappointed her has seen
that before like you'd pay to watch
softcore so dumb so after we
fast-forwarded through it realize what
it was
I called guest relations and the
Filipino guy was like huh I said I
ordered this movie and and there's
there's no penetration
and he goes blah I said I wanted
hardcore want to see it going in and out
check with his manager and he was like
okay we're refunding no we checked
we asked him are there any hardcore ones
I don't want to see softcore
waste of my time and money so then he
put us on whole and he asked his manager
if they're ready for hardcore film good
debate baby bang my Triple D slap egg
whites I have such a soft spot for that
lady yeah as you know she's like you
know what we're here to do just go yeah
she was like come on I gotta pick my kid
up from school three quit debating God
just do bro yeah I mean class the
[ __ ] come on yeah you can tell us
she's just like yeah it's horrible pick
up the pace a little bit it's horrible
you know I back to your thing about
attractive people I was thinking about
it right that a lot of them become like
trainers personal trainers I see him as
a it's a it's an exercise in their own
vanity no yeah yeah there's a trainer my
friend Mary Lynn showed me a picture of
on Instagram and I was like this guy's
like perfectly giver see somebody who's
so attractive just perfect that you're I
can't even look at your it makes me
uncomfortable also grams the place to
find them by the way they have found
their their place in this social media
world yeah if Instagram you just like if
you open your explore page sometimes
they're just beautiful people and you go
there and it's like it's not any one of
like any known field or Talent they're
just like I'm incredibly good-looking
yeah and I'm sharing it with all of you
yeah it's amazing hold that's there for
them
do they get paid do you think I think if
you build up enough followers you
definitely get paid just for being
good-looking well it's just like that
Cameron Dallas boy that we watch the
Netflix show about all those boys by the
way I love their Instagram feeds because
they're all really cute and that's all
they do and then they do meet and greets
and they make a ton of money but here's
the best part on Instagram you see what
they're spending their money on oh oh
and right now it's like here's my new
Lamborghini went along with the doors
that come up or whatever like DeLorean
type here's my this place I'm renting
right now in the Hollywood Hills and
you're like do you're renting like buy a
house like they're renting these really
expensive how
they're getting ridiculous cars are
going on ridiculous occasions like
you're just burning through if I got
that kind of money at 16 yeah din who
are you going to do so stupid you feel
like I'm going to get this forever you
don't think that would ever slow down no
I know what are they going to do when
they turn 30 it's like 30 what about
when they turn 20 I'm going to go away I
know I'm gonna be cute little kids
anymore oh my goodness what are we doing
I don't know stuff like this problem
[Music]
yes sir and Rockley oh yes yes there's
$600 meet-and-greets
easy make six hundred thousand in a
weekend's Christ can you imagine how
painful that is but that is such that's
also a very daunting clip because it's
like is he liking it or not sorry right
down the middle yeah there's moments of
both feelings yeah yeah here's something
that's horribly upsetting yeah Oh
goddammit this is like this pisses me
off that this even exists this is real
see the design will need to move from
being able T to and be tabled through
choice nonprofit stunts Troy I got it
yeah where's my cane everyone a button
now out there yeah if you're like wait
what do they want
largest number want some for meditation
one either normal two legs or one or two
arms a number wants to be paralyzed and
come and they have a very specific point
at which they want mobility to be power
line I mean okay and here you just beat
the [ __ ] right and I know that and
worship here's the thing is that we're
supposed to be super tolerant of
everybody's needs and emotional stage
but at what point can we just be like
you know what you're [ __ ] mentally
ill yeah okay you got problems and you
need to go see a shrink
use your heads [ __ ] up yeah you are
you're [ __ ] weird why can't we just
call people weird anymore or abnormal
hey guess what your psychology it's
abnormal you're not normal it was up
it's a bad back on people saying that
too much for everything
like in other words people were told
you're not normal if you're gay right
right feelings pushback is that anything
anything you want is embraced you want
to you want to amputate your arms to
feel special and different yeah go ahead
your [ __ ] [ __ ] and total [ __ ] I
mean I really it enrages me that
somebody is going to sign up for that
like [ __ ] you know lucky you are
well if you're going to add me to your
arm then donate it to a vet who just had
his [ __ ] arms blown off by an ie D
and Afghanistan goal totally expected to
one single blind once to becomes like
your episode of this guy understand me
through speed go for it good please so
you don't reproduce we need to move away
from pathologize uh-huh appreciating the
enemy was 50 thank you okay no you know
what pretending they're not thanking me
hard get over it
playing it if you think that they won't
elect moved oh my good but we shouldn't
help them no and we shouldn't feel badly
for them no I think we should go back to
reap a solid izing the imple you need to
call them [ __ ] weirdos and an
abnormal they come into a room yeah a
couple of [ __ ] baseball bat there you
go and give them a real [ __ ] beating
and then afterwards egg you still want
to lose anyway that's what you should do
and see if they feel the same way yeah
yeah you know what I think the problem
is is that we don't institutionalize
people anymore I think Reagan
deinstitutionalized a lot of the
mentally ill in the 80s and since then
the thought of putting somebody in a
mental hospital is considered very taboo
but I think you should I think there are
people who need to be locked up I mean
what does this guy want to do celebrate
them ya know I'm right there's a whole
group of dumb people out there they want
to do some dumb shits themselves and we
should all be there to help support
talking about why we have to support
every stupid thing that exists so [ __ ]
some [ __ ] you don't have to support some
stuff is this is wrong I mean imagine
the person listening to this who was a
Wed to fight for our country and had his
yeah her arms yeah I've blown off and
sitting and listening to this [ __ ]
exactly that's that's what I'm saying
like people have been an accident or
stupid and they're like yeah it's been a
real thrill that this happened and you
want this to happen yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you and your stupid arm you're dead dude
very very Cassie considers emotions and
you present it for number dumb station
the only fool
yeah all I'm hearing though is that they
want to do it he hasn't said that like
and then they did it you realize that
good when your doctor is going to
voluntarily we know I want them to do it
in their [ __ ] backyards like I want
to hear the story of that you know what
that's a great idea is if you're gonna
do it you got to do it yeah get like a
wooden yeah what is that just like a
cut-off tree a stomp in the backyard
into an axe and if you can do it a
church you don't get to do it no I want
to make youtube videos though again when
I am yeah where you got to have to have
a horrible or hilarious segment see if I
saw hilarious as far as I'm concern for
these [ __ ] most people will know
these feelings can't I just say feeling
so they do I mean good way can we just
wait society needs appreciate so much
however strange insane
yeah yeah didn't build able to allow
people to align the whole tea with a
feeling no can I say also got a problem
with today's society is that just
because you feel something doesn't mean
you have a legitimate right to act on
every [ __ ] impulse I know healing is
a lot of feeling out there yeah yeah
it's like you feel really feeling I feel
a lot of ways to I don't know you just
[ __ ] sit on this feeling right are
you sublimate those feelings through
healthier outlet right so maybe I want
to be an amputee well maybe how about
not coming arm up but maybe I do artwork
about amputees where I work with people
with the you know why don't you uh gann
up for a jujitsu school to see if
they'll break your [ __ ] arm like just
stay bad at it
and then that'll happen that's for the
best guy every week and just be like
armbar me bro just see if you can just
keep cracking us yeah
maybe that'll so go to a few Klan
rallies yeah let's go to the Klan rally
well I'm to say my an LA and get the
[ __ ] be nutty or just wear like a trump
shirt in LA in LA you know what I mean
do something stupid
okay yes speaking of raging it is
horrible or hilarious this is one that
came in poof
I don't know if I can even handle this
one what just happened what just
happened what was that what was that
what was that what is that what is that
what I'm not looking I'm not I'm out his
nut King laughs when I came out oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh god oh god oh
god I didn't like that hey look at that
this is my good one smiler I don't know
what happened
I don't know that's it he tied a rope to
his balls and then jumped I don't know
what is that what it was I don't know
what he did everything's I'm upset oh I
guess oh my god oh my god oh my god guys
oh my god who did not came out dude my
god dude oh my God look at that guy he's
like I'm leaving dude it's not cool
we have an incident at the Heritage Park
in Bali Virginia my friend Kiki tied a
rope he tied a rope to himself and they
took off runnin off a tree it was just
like it was just like fooling around and
like a bunch of guys were around we were
just goofing off and you know he ended
up ripping his like his testicle yeah
okay well that's a horrible one dollar
one okay let's take it let's take a
breather thankful so well okay that was
a full [ __ ] stoppage you actually
changed clothes you were so traumatized
blue band is here he's adjusting the
lighting because we're having a guest
come in soon that's the thing that we
wanted to announce that we're actually
having a guest in studio for the first
time in well first time here and also
the first time in I don't know it's got
to be like two years or something yeah
because once we move from the from
Redondo to house and then we were
recording the show next to our sons
nursery so we didn't really want to have
guests coming in and out of our baby's
room eventually so it's been a while
it's been a while but here we are and
we're you know you know we're set up for
a guest but listen turns out that guy
cuz I didn't want to look again yeah he
tied a rope to his ball bag yes stupid
jumped with the other end tied to a tree
so stupid what anything my god we
happened yeah yeah yeah yeah I thought I
saw the Rope as I do he did not just
well the verdict is in horrible or
hilarious it was [ __ ] horrible
horrible wait so you didn't even find
that I thought it was funny in the
beginning because I was like that's just
a dumb kid and then now what what made
it not funny for you dude any ball
related traumas not funny to me I can't
I can't do it just because it's a guy
guy hurting his nuts I can't do it
oh yeah you you have empathy is that
what you're saying in those situations
yet you're able to put yourself in
somebody else's shoes
yes and feel that pain can I tie a rope
around your balls no just for fun
no you're not into that it's a little
tug tug tug traumatic yeah yeah hold on
can I can I bring up another topic
before we move along sure I really want
to get this in it's super important the
other day you were calling me from
horrigan and Iran I was on the phone
here at home you're on the phone
and Corrigan and I was talking and I had
to fess up and tell you the truth that I
was actually sitting on the toilet
making Amanda I'm sorry but I gotta go
I'm taking a [ __ ] and I realized I
couldn't [ __ ] with you on the phone it
didn't feel honest yeah and then use it
I said you're never going to believe
this I'm browning too they were both
browning at the same time it's synergy
right yeah and I hit the mute button so
that you didn't hear right like when you
would start talking I would hitting you
and then push really that was my problem
with browning with you is that I would
have I was afraid you were going to hear
my sounds - but that was really
thoughtful of me you agreed on that yeah
I was really nice and I wish I had
thought of that strategy of muting I
didn't even think of it it was crazy to
me because I thought I'd snuck in there
why did we did I didn't do that and then
you're like I gotta tell you I'm Brian
haha I can't leave it you are so excited
you know you seldom show emotion or
excitement yeah I mean even when I told
you I was pregnant you're like stop it
yeah somebody send us email speaking of
Brown is it gross to brown at a strip
club now I need the segura to settle the
situation happened I believe only top
dog and bun so me and my dad can provide
a balanced perspective on this on Friday
my bus fare and I went to a sleazy strip
club to enjoy adult entertainment my
friend Dan had a couple beers and he
said where is the pisser in this joint
emotion to the hallway next to the DJ
booth I turned my attention back to the
ladies grinding and their removing their
clothes 25 minutes later Dan came out
look at them
apparently Dan decided to take a [ __ ] in
the bathroom at a strip club the savage
animal will [ __ ] anywhere I feel like
[ __ ] in a circle is never allowed
this is the most foul and horrid place
to relieve oneself here's the question
is it reasonable to make brown I think
it's reasonable I think so and here's
why yeah strip clubs are disgusting
places to begin one yeah okay that
sounds like that's his logic for why not
to do it and I think that's that's odd I
think if we every angle [ __ ] out at
night at bars and stuff though I think
that's not you're at a bar and you're
taking a [ __ ] that's differently it's
weird you got a [ __ ] at that hour you
know I had a friend that every time we
go nightclubbing and high school in
college the minute we get to the club
she'd have to [ __ ] really every time
that nerves over so nervous and so she
would be like often go five to go
[ __ ] [ __ ] at this club I mean it's
just uncomfortable
yeah to [ __ ] at a nightclub yeah people
are waiting in line I think anywhere
where there's a long line of people and
it's not really now I do get by the way
I guess he's saying you know there's so
many gross dudes and they don't
obviously don't care for the facilities
but I mean most bathrooms are pretty
gross as I'm saying at the strip club
like guys are obviously pissing and
probably jerking off all over those
terms but I mean you know to show you
have to [ __ ] yeah these guys gotta take
a dump but I think anywhere well here's
an ideal place to [ __ ] when there's lots
of stalls like a you know a Dodger game
is fine yeah
Airport ideal for [ __ ] because
there's a lot of traffic in and now it's
quick people make quick trips you know
yeah I got a message here this is 395
Audio trouble there's trouble in 395
really you see this oh there's an audio
problem the episode when Tom plays an
audio clip of Sarah burns voice mother
is a constant howling in my ear I know a
lot of barking do dad moving stupid
actually every voice message my friends
I'll take a packet oh let me know this
issue can be resolved thanks Chris Wow
harab ah now I know what do you mean I
know it means seeing it dogs Bitsey is
in love with blue band you know what you
eat before you come over here but this
dog can't stop licking him yeah I do
flavor she loves Wow two flavors
what are you eating Capel to fish your
hands covered and lox before you come
over and she love the associates love
this just for a reference
uh here you see here is why is this not
working
listen can I talk about my experiment
when you're looking for that then did
you line it so our son it turns out is
lactose intolerant and you and I did
that 23andme genetic testing a while
back and it revealed that I was lactose
intolerance truth which really makes
sense because I [ __ ] hate milk and
every time I would have ice cream my
stomach would just be wrecked I would
get gas bubbles like really painful yeah
I can eat cheese pretty much is fine but
milk liquid it destroys me so my son has
it now we stopped feeding him regular
milk he drinks lactose free milk and I
thought oh yeah he's totally fine now
and I thought to myself what if I just
tried drinking some milk and just to see
it was really yeah the thing that I know
that's true is really right so maybe you
have to verify it yeah
and so I drank the milk and sure enough
I [ __ ] like three times laughter and it
was really painful and so guess what I'm
lactose intolerant but just for milk
yeah and you already knew this and I
knew this but I wanted to retest the
theory here is just to be clear I pulled
up Byrnes voicemail stop it and then you
see it says stupid she's gorgeous
I know here's Mary Lynn yeah I can see
what you meant
Mary Lynn Rajskub also star of 24 your
friend Sean evil
fantastically good-looking Sean if I was
their last name and then yeah I mean
she's very good-looking too all my
friends are very attractive and there
you are talking
yeah I don't know what they I mean it
sounds like that was the issue but I
mean it's I like it sweetie you're
saying my friends are the dog pound
what what kind of lookers do you think
you have in your bunch I was in your
corner burner bugs all right ha ha ha ha
bad it's working comedian out there yeah
my god who's your hi friends and movin
no Jew [ __ ] yo yo man yo come on
who else do you have now your friends
are lovely this is you no no your
friends are dogs okay okay oh man that
was fun that's a good time your your
where to do that guy yeah oh yeah yeah
no I'm this done it they're all they're
all unattractive your friends are lovely
they are they are lovely yeah they're
good-looking one of them would you marry
oh they're all marriage material
they are yeah yeah yeah they've all been
married or are married yeah they're all
marriage material
okay now I would I would put in all of
them stop it what I didn't say put it in
I said marry now I would I was finishing
all of them stop it what the problem
with my friends they all got a hungry
tits and you like slopper oh no they
anger doesn't matter really no of course
not I thought you were into big flops I
like to its period I don't care what
size they are
yeah but you like I'm hanging my [ __ ]
purple there or they can be hungry and
starving doesn't matter I don't care put
them in put them put them everywhere
leave them out I like him do you like
blondes that but still I mean none of
them are blind hey if she is the grass
on the field snow dead too dumb huh so
down was that is because you can is all
pink on the inside
Oh God does so she's pretty fine here's
a dad boner this one's pretty [ __ ]
great this dad boner decides to go
fishing with a drone looks like his own
little experiment today we're going to
doing something that's another internet
first and totally outrageous
we're going to go fishing lovey yeah
we're not using worms and we're not
little cause we are on Lake Champlain
and we are going to be trolling with the
jitterbug
oh that's the others girls did you hit a
nearby so then the drone look here it is
like that it's mine oh my gosh my fishes
you did see the fish Jeff I got a fish
oh my gosh oh my god
I guess oh my gosh holy crab apples crab
at all the weight he that that's just on
him oh my gosh Marion my god
Marion cases oh my gosh that's crazy
that drone cosmos alright ma'am I wish
you get this excited for me like when
you yell for me it comes man I love that
right look I want I thought when the
drone it's a huge freaking bat sorry
tell me the numbers on my GoPro are
rolling more get that size of this got
you camera crews quickly so found out
you got to hurry up my god put the
Marion's like I am so where's i'ma shoot
sideways
quick quick quick turn the site where
the front sideways Marion's got a
newborn in her arm two other little ones
and this [ __ ] excited about his fish
actually I know she's like anything is
important that you're doing she's like
could you just [ __ ] help me with his
babies right now Miriam
yeah he's talked about it oh my gosh
yeah I'd be so mad at him I like his dad
boner style a chance for the game I do
wish you a crabapple sky level I wish
you would get excited about anything
like that I do get excited about what
though different things nothing in life
is that exciting nothing no come on
I've never seen you get that gig done
anything that's not true
never not excitement excitements not
your thing like personality chance get
excited about god dammit you're just not
not very excitable or fun or I'm pretty
excitable no never
you can't think of one time you never
like jump up and down like oh yeah it's
so rad did it it yeah
watching sports sometimes like it can
you do yeah okay I'll take that back no
ball football you like that excite
murder you see me jump and scream and
claw you know [ __ ] yeah yeah
angry like anger but sometimes you get
really excited you do yeah at that
football there you go that's a good one
okay come on don't be non-binary I want
to amputate one of my arms that's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] man you've gotta
respect people Tom there no you don't
and everybody has a right to have their
feelings I'm going to write to act on
their irrational feelings no the other
day you're in the kitchen and you pulled
your legs up you're in your boxer shorts
you pull your legs up to your ears and
then you farted at me
yeah and I feel like this might be a
turning point for us and what sway just
like in the way of like is this it like
are we are we brother and sister now
like a lot if you like you can think of
me as a woman
yeah I'm 100 I do of course uh-huh like
somebody that you have sex with or you
know that you see me as like an opposite
sex person yeah you totally are mm-hmm
yeah I totally see you as that until
whatever we were courting 12 years ago
like we just started dating would you
pull your legs up and forgot me at the
table then or guys are twelve years in
the game and you feel like that's in the
game we're in the game I mean I actually
have I recorded your response when I
farted there right hit it on my phone
here you are I'm a big dog I like that
there I am I'm a breath on save yeah
very Brussels birth so I'm a small dog
yeah
little Brussels feelings you sure yeah
yeah that's me
so that's how I would barger you I don't
think we're over the line you think
across those yeah I think anything we
may have overstepped seriously we may
have entered in a territory like
officially in it for life and double the
double leg back pool yeah in your
underwear yeah what those that may have
may have put us into weird territory we
should get the house phone it's a smart
idea to know when can you run in there
do you mind it's on the counter do you
think that that may have may have
affected us I feel like I can't unsee it
that's the problem like there's a reason
you and I don't [ __ ] in front of each
other yeah because I feel like that one
but that would put us in a territory
like no going back we're brother and
sister now
yeah I agree we don't do that we
shouldn't [ __ ] in friendship I mean I
don't know if this has been the line
crossing somebody sent in this evidence
that you you are the fart champ says I
am let's see though let's see what it
says I like those dog barks I love dogs
evidence that Tina I am is a fart champ
2013 episode 145 13 with you and you
have this horrible gas problem you just
let them rip all day and I'm like I love
her what am I supposed to do and then
you say you thought a lot more than me I
think and I say no and you say who do
you think farts more and I said you so
it's kind of weird in this instance
we're actually roll you're declaring
declining that you are I'm insisting
that you it was 2013 yeah Wow my things
have changed since then yeah so you you
insisted that I was a fart champion this
person says that huh
in episodes 1 2 3 94 yeah there is clear
irrefutable evidence episode 1 that that
Tom Segura is the personality champ-
yeah
based on the promised hours he's more
charming
more likeable overall personality wrong
Dylan you have many people I meet when I
do my shows that come up to me and
they're like you're the personality
champ you're the best and then I just
get tweets all day long it's like I
can't even look at my Twitter feed how
much personality ask I don't thinks I'm
going to do and you have just uh
robles a penis yeah you just let him rip
all day oh yeah me and I'm like I love
her Who am I supposed to do there you go
you fart a lot more than me I think no
readings words more you little [ __ ] you
no way you let out a couple monster ones
last night and or this morning this
morning you know we ate a lot of
prosciutto and cheese last night for
dinner yeah you and you are insisting
that I was right and you were saying
that you weren't you were saying if you
want to know what sometimes we're not
always ready for greatness
yeah it's like you you become great over
time you're not always ready to accept
the title so that's what this is all
about Tomcat this podcast is about
discovering oneself yeah
I'm discovering them you're kind of
heads up it's the farts of that feed bro
like we're that deep bro is for yourself
for farts yeah discovering yeah it's a
it's pretty pretty wild that that we've
gotten to this point where you're really
finding out who's who and what's what
you know yeah being my Triple D [ __ ]
wife whoa Lubin doesn't know about that
Alan mm-hmm
you'll hear it that's better we kept
saying that title over and over to our
so run over stupid bang my Triple D [ __ ]
wife bring them Triple D [ __ ] wife yeah
that's what it sounds like
yeah bang my Triple D [ __ ] wife yeah
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah bang my Triple D [ __ ] life so any
moment we should be joined by somebody
it's gonna be I think we should leave it
as a surprise
yeah until it gets here just be sharing
at age yeah of course
and it's not what you expect it's not a
comic now an entertainer but it is a
field that is of great interest to both
to both of us
well I'm more of an aficionado I don't
think so as usual you're ruining a great
moment but I think you guys will
probably find this as interesting
contempt I rolling those are all signs
of doors
what about them contempt for your spouse
that's the predictor of divorce and I
Rowling is a huge predictor and a lot
both from this family but what about it
you constantly have content and I want
you for I don't contantly have content
oh no I know no harm honor comes from
where is he
she's here something I have come all
over my face somebody tweeted a was it
Sean Spicer to see if he had heard about
the comb strike one of the White House
had commented yeah this administration
think of the common strike what's going
on the what yeah for in far in come
strike now I masturbated to everybody in
my family is so not to nuts
she's so [ __ ] crazy I can't even
imagine
hey so our [ __ ] stupid dogs ran away
last week we lived that nothing narrow
it was terrifying this interval so I was
in here recording that's deep bro and I
was dinner time yeah so I open that I
usually keep them in here to record and
then I let them into the house for
dinner time thinking that you know
everybody would be there and I should
have checked to make sure that the the
kitty door was shut we had like a
childproof fence
yeah and I for some reason I looked and
I was like oh that's fine I didn't even
like double-check
I'm come back in here to record you come
in here like is it are the dogs in here
and the dogs in here I'm like no I
didn't say are the dogs in here I said
it's beef and feast I had a bit shocked
so what happened was I was upstairs I
was on my computer the phone rings
there's somebody outside and he goes
your dog bitsy oh my god like yeah
you know I have her outside so I run
outside he just stand this dude who I
would not have guessed would be the type
of guy to do this he did not look like a
kind of homeless no he just looked kind
of um oh no just kinda ready yeah you've
heard like a gapper or something yeah so
I take bitsy in and then I'm in by the
way on I go downstairs the front doors
open the front door to our house is open
tetanus and then I grab her I'm
terrified and I'm looking all around for
I thought it peace with you and then
when he isn't like oh [ __ ] and we just
go outside and we started looking for
them or looking for feet because it's
his back here man
we drove all over this neighborhood I
was yelling out the window absolutely
wrong welcome
oh my god my favorite by the way is when
we we found there was one guy and I was
like have you seen a dog a small blonde
dog and he goes yeah no no I haven't
seen it because you should find it
before the Sun Goes Down all those
coyotes come out and I go thanks dude
yeah I don't thank you I was like of
course we're gonna we're going to stop
looking for him like I guess the sun's
now we're going to stop looking for the
dog that we've loved for the last six
years
this was [ __ ] of course we're going
to keep due to anyway we finally I did a
phone call actually we saw the woman
walking away from our house because he
left me a voicemail it didn't come true
yeah one of the neighbors found fifo in
her yard got three houses down four
houses down and got attacked there we we
walked cheese to that area too but he he
was you know he's only what you inches
off the ground just such as scary though
it was really scary
I was the whole time I kept thinking I
won't be able to sleep tonight if we
don't find fifo I would I would just be
beside myself with grief
yeah it was my firstborn son I know how
many hours and labor and I spent with
that guy
anyways I bought a jeep dog gps for both
of them they're both chipped but that
you know that microchip [ __ ] doesn't
work unless somebody turns them into a
vet or turns them into the shelter yeah
so the chip is not GPS not the same
thing yeah and so I got the GPS and I'm
charging them now and then you put it on
the collar and you can see it on your
cell phone where they are can't wait and
there's an electric fence thing so that
if they go out of bounds it'll notify
you we got this email from a listener
hiding it hopes to shed some light on
this dick farting phenomenon so we can
all know thank you what's going on here
I was glassing over your recent podcast
and I thought this could be a fantastic
learning experience for all involved
Crohn's is a chronic inflammatory
condition with that inflammation
something called fistula is conformed
fistula is basically a little tube that
connects to hollow organs these
conformed between your bowel and blood
vessels your skin and even yes your
bladder the last sort of fistula form is
called an enter o vascular fistula air
and water waste products can travel from
the bow into the bladder this causes an
amazing dick farting phenomena that we
have grown to love today I'm actually
graduating from medical school in the
week congrat I know what I'm saying
know what I'm saying put some respect on
my left on my name I love you find the
dick farting expert really go right here
dig for it I didn't dig boy do the dick
farts yeah do the dick fart smell like
farts I bet you know no one touched on
that no one touched on that I mean it's
air so it could stink well he says it
comes from the bowel good so so I'm
assuming that those dick farts smell
like real farts man this tube was
pissing in his parts we're coming out of
the stick okay would you rather I think
this our guest is going to know what the
topics are before he gets here we can
chime in
would you rather tie a string around
your balls and jump off no puss named
ass bench or have dick parts for the
rest of your life honored thousands a
far today
I just every time I take it out just
parts a song okay
would you rather dick farts for the rest
of your life
yep or one drink from that guy's nipple
uh I'd have to be like super thirsty oh
he's like I a softy and you're like I'm
so sorry Todd I'm so thirsty daddy
that's what you have to say daddy give
me the milk I'm so thirsty
damn it I don't know where he is oh he's
here say in German are you funny see if
you have a gentleman to you sick never
wash lucky boy I think I shake I think I
would take one of those over a lifetime
of dick farts yeah yeah
dick farts it would be really bad though
to do this this would be really bad
he doesn't have milk in his breast for
my ball [ __ ] vomit going on now do men
have milk ducts I think they do I think
you could
can you lactate man I wonder can men
listen I mean I don't know our nipples
are different some I don't know but you
had milk it's so gross it's so
description medical doctor guy can men's
lactate can men produce milk I know that
they must have similar equipment look in
utero that's why men have stop it with
the [ __ ] bark oh yeah you know I
don't like it ha ha ha don't laugh leave
in a legitimate phobia I have I [ __ ]
hate it yeah si yeah it's real it's a
[ __ ] real mental problem I have I see
a [ __ ] shrink for it yeah ok I am it
and so it is here for me I love doing
that to you I know you do
that's what that's what happens on this
ok no contempt no so let's uh let's
break and hopefully in a few moments few
minutes will
returned with a guest that we're very
excited about show me how the dick fart
smell okay we'll be right back
all right so we're back and you don't
know that before you got here this show
had a lot of different topics most of
them were between our n 217 and xxx and
now it's a total change of pace and
we're very happy to welcome by the way
you are our first guest I'm not
exaggerating here in a couple years
oh my gosh we used to have guests all
the time mark did it I fan now the
owners we have the foremost water
sommelier in the United States and
actually in the world yeah you in the
both know sometimes scary show me can't
get closer that all right some sometimes
it's scary show me that I'm that famous
already and as you are it's Martin Rees
correct yeah read it actually it's like
Porsche Porsche alright we've reset does
it annoy you how many people say Porsche
wrong they should say Porsche right I'm
braced you bred German yes we live with
the snow that I want to give people yeah
the background to this so what happened
was I actually saw a different one of
your competitors water sommelier on CNN
there's a piece on him and he was in
Asia Shanghai away meets him in June who
is this guy do you like him do you hate
him no we don't know y'all I love
everybody who drinks water well makes me
like me
not town that's what I don't like at by
the way it's all Tom I saw I'm wearing a
water champ at for those of you
listening
right I saw this piece and I thought oh
this is fascinating then I saw it's in
Shanghai and I go well I guess that'll
never happen then I'm on Instagram and I
see this 60 second piece on you and I'm
watching I'm like oh cool another water
swimming it and then I see in LA
immediately I go to your website and
it's Martin - Reese calm and I email
about a class you do like privates or
high group class and you hit me back and
you said like you're the water champ how
about that
not other factually accurate Martin that
is I haven't happened you you have no
idea not right back to you and say
you're the water it's exactly what he
said I'll show you the email just now
now here's the thing just to get people
like most people know the word sommelier
and that that always is you know
high-end restaurant they have a
sommelier to tell you about wines and
their origin and how do you come about
becoming a water sommelier so I have to
say it started when I was a child so on
vacation time with my parents I tasted
the different tap waters all around the
world when I was on vacation and my
parents always thought like hey what's
wrong with our son is like and running
to the tap when we end in the city or
something it's like what's what's up
with him
and for me it was like hey mother what
do you think about the taste of the tap
water and she's like what it's like
what's up it's like no and for me as a
child about fascinating that everybody
said yeah tap water and I felt like but
there are so many different nuances in
tap water even isn't it funny though
that this is something that basically we
all I feel like everybody senses that
but you acted on it in other words we
all tried tap waters as a kid especially
and you're like that but I feel like
you're the one who was talking about it
I think the thing is with kids and I see
it right now in my water
tasting class that's well kids love that
the course kids taste pets are still
like super fresh they are not like
completely wound already because they
didn't have too much spicy food or drink
oh I'll go to something like this for
grass so they can really detect a lot of
stuff wait water so you say that that
can actually dull your palate is having
spicy foods or drinking recording you
get accounting so many different like
taste profiles and water is very
settling taste we know more about wine
were like different colors different
grapes different vintages different
barrel fermentations by water it's
hopefully all comes from nature and it's
all about the mineral content so as a
child I realized what has taste and then
in 2005 I worked in a restaurant in
Germany at the restaurant first floor
and customer came up to me and said hey
Martin he have so many different wines
but you just having one brand of water
and I don't like this particular brand
do you have something else for me and I
was like looking at him and I thought I
care about his subsidy right in the
restaurant business all about
options you have different liquors if
different beers on tap you have
different lines on the menu but when it
comes to water the Sun will ask you
sparking little tap right what are you
right gargling or bottled never cap yeah
I thought hey I should change and I
wanted to give options to my guests I
created a Waterman in 2005 so a lot of
people always sing like Oh only in LA
there's of water some of you yeah
actually I'm doing this over 10 years
now so now this is so cool man and like
all our water competitions aside we are
big fans of what like water in general
like we we always start because you know
we we were both drinking water and and
had this banter back and forth about
like who drinks more but the truth is I
do love trying out different waters and
I feel like I don't know I can't speak
for the rest of the world but it's
always a thing here in the United States
that that argument about you know if you
go and you and you buy this water it's
just that's just a someone took their
their their hose in the back and fill
this thing up right and and you have to
how many comments I had on my social
media pages about this come on Martin
you just have a big hole somewhere in
your backyard and you're putting all the
different different water shapes and
then you're putting all this water and
they think yeah right but there really
is serious differences I mean I think
the inexperienced person knows that that
you know different waters taste
differently but in its easiest form to
explain the difference really comes down
to mineral content right right so it can
measure by GDS total two cell phones
okay one question though because I grew
up in LA and never drank the tap wire I
mean I'm convinced it's just poison
running through and so it's also like
what do you buy as what does the average
person buy to have in their home so
that's another thing I would ask you
because we did Sparkletts for a while
and that was fine but now we have a
water filtration system built into our
house and that's I don't know is it
better so that - I would like to know
from you so the thing is when it comes
to modern I think the biggest important
thing is that people need to understand
where their water is coming from and it
is kind of sad that here in America a
lot of purified water companies are like
the new hit thing and everybody thinks
water should be pure I'm always saying
water should not be pure
when it's completely pure you don't want
to drink it because your body needs
minerals all the time like magnesium
calcium potassium silicon all these
different minerals what your body cannot
produce by myself so your body needs
constantly minerals there isn't you
hungry yes the reason you're thirsty
because your body wants minerals so to
have a water kind of like say a tap
water fill that everything out of there
and then it's like super pure water pure
with zero TDS it's actually extremely
harmful for your body and you have no
minerals no minerals so your body drinks
that Mother Nature doesn't know the
concept of completely pure water it
doesn't exist another nature right so
you're drinking that water the body
things like what the hell is that it's
like I don't even know what this element
is know what I just drunk I need to put
minerals in it to process it to get rid
of it so you're actually dehydrating by
dribble I knew it I knew it can I tell
you because when I did drink tap water
like on the emergency days and we'd run
out of Sparkletts I swear I would feel
thirsty or after drinking tap water it
never but there are funds the rate of
water and I don't want to radio mines no
ya le tap water is actually way more
minerals then I hit refine water
companies really so when you want to
stick to mineral content drink a liter
what so I think even when I would choose
a bottle of like a purified water and
you can see it on the label purified
water here what I brought it's all
spring waters and that's the only thing
I always promote you have waters I've
never never heard of this is what I'm so
excited about I mean I there's
definitely I would say amongst I will
call us the the regular civilians who
are not in your your League of knowledge
everybody kind of kind of thinks that
Fiji is the you know between Evian and
feed you they're like those are that's
high-end water he's usually you pay more
for those two in a convenience store you
know 7-eleven and I in my own palate I
do feel like I taste Fiji as different
than other bottled waters that are
around other words VM the whatever
yellow spray I forget there's a Florida
Springs one and there's
Dasani which had a dog shed I don't like
spending it a terrible on his purified
it's purified here my job in this
resource water filtering everything out
of there they're adding make some very
small amount of minerals like that
amount yeah and then sending it flying
price in my opinion the biggest game on
planet Earth is Dasani yes in general
horrified water company yeah well show
me something what I want drives me crazy
and I will came to the state in 2011 and
I wanted to create a water menu right
away and it was so hard to find real
spring waters in America yeah because
mostly here the waters are purified
waters and it seems that hey they are
all bind big companies and the big
companies wants to make money as
coca-cola Danone Manor and Pepsi are the
four biggest water producers in the
world
and they all want to make money with us
yeah so therefore it's easier to use
just tap water filtering everything out
of there adding extra minerals just for
taste profile that's like the waters
kind of okay and sending it for price
yeah therefore I'm sticking always to
spring water and this is what I always
recommend when you go into a grocery
store just check the labels look for
spring glacier or natural source mineral
water and do not buy purified water
don't buy outright water okay so you're
essentially doing harm to yourself with
I don't want to say hum but but yeah you
harm yourself definitely buy distilled
water when you're buying the niak
gallons or my mother you buy that shinra
salt water it's created for like outer
batteries it's for your iron it's not
for consumption right and in Germany
they're big labels on this bottles what
you can buy us one the grocery store do
not drink not for human consumption rely
on America the idea whatever distilled
water that's so good so pure so
marketing plays a big role and there are
water companies and I see still people
at the gym with a gallon of distilled
water taking that down and then they're
wondering why they're suddenly like
feeling not really good and you either
always have headaches India dehydrated
oh yeah yeah that's what I drank during
that water cut when I was doing a weight
loss contest you're trying to cut water
these the last few days fighters they
told me that the way you do it is you
drink distilled water to flush your
clothes it's nothing ever exactly so
over a longer time oh yeah no no it's
World Health Organization isn't saying
it can be very harmful for me
for a long time what about Avion is that
a good one I feel like it takes a mini
it just tastes so pure and good so that
one's again and that's so funny if you
had a has a laugh and hate relationship
to guests it's so funny some people
saying I love Avion some people think I
hate Avion
and that is the reason why I have a
water menu and the restaurant is so
actually so simple when you think about
it is actually a very simple concept can
we tell the people what restaurant
patina Restaurant at the world is to
consider and that is downtown Los
Angeles and roll I went to interview for
a job there like 10 plus years ago hey
yeah my sister used to work for the
patina group that is fun and so she set
me up and I went in for an interview and
I didn't get the job was it that big
joke you know what was it no no like she
like set me up for a forget if it was
hosting or I don't know something like
that zero restaurant experience but I
went in and like I had on a suit it's a
funny kind of try - I should say I know
if people who have viewer experience
yeah the court then I can actually form
them yeah yeah that's way better for me
I like people we sing dinner what Martin
I never walked in the restaurant before
but I really get to do it and I'm a
husband guy that's for me thousand times
better than people who come in to me and
say like yeah I'm worked in all this
fancy places and I know way more than
you do right that's true yeah right oh
this will be trouble already
that's true I applied to work at Lowry
steakhouse downtown but then I failed
the drug test because I smoked pot the
night before you did the night before
she's starting not smart to relax for
the day
no I'm excited to jump in and try some
waters hi another thing we did because
we were talking about this even before
you got it definitely do I have a glass
of our filtered system water can I give
you our man I put too much in it but I
went to a days want to see what's really
interesting keeps mental difference the
first thing what I'm doing and this is
already when people say like what the
hell is Martin doing why is he looking
at a glass of water
yeah and I can already see something
like if there's any mineral content if I
can see something on the TDS levels but
there's like it looks pretty pure to me
in this way there are some the residues
right here but this might be the glass
of Polish turmeric so let's see smelling
there's no chlorine smell so that's
already a good sign because your
filtration systems obviously
shape because sometimes the problem with
rotation system is as well that people
buying themselves a filtration system
yeah I never think about maybe changing
the soldiers oh I'm on top of it because
it has a light that tells me when it
turns yellow I buy the photos I'm a lot
of pictures there filtration system in
their fridges yeah they think like oh I
got my great water from the fridge and
they are like putting this for many many
years orders which never change their
filter what that means this orders
backed up one at one point with all this
stuff what you don't want have in your
water and then it's actually harmful the
shoulders so filled up that is actually
point for water what's going on yeah
these guys when you have a filtration
system at home changing your name sure
to change your filters all the time sure
cheers cheers Cheers cheers Cheers
see words in English so the middle
content is very low you can pay this
right away um it's a it's a plan what I
think to drink this stuff but the
mineral content is love banana cannot
resist some normal this is Tory know
that I think if I have a filtration
system at home as well so don't worry
about it
I'm using it like for showering for
cooking for all this kind of stuff yeah
but when it comes to adjust regular
drinking on a daily basis I'm sticking
to bottled water because every F I want
to have a little variety as well and all
of these that we're looking at here
these all are different to the palate
every single one of these oh yeah
definitely and price-wise like when we
when we talk about for instance wines
right wines people who don't buy wines a
lot they just go that's really expensive
it must be amazing and don't realize
that a lot of the times what the price
is indicated above is the exclusivity of
it in other words they make less of
these therefore the price is much higher
executive same with Botox so this is the
more expensive ones are just less like
mass-produced yeah for example I brought
several waters here and this skilled is
a good example for wine the skilled is
way more expensive than maybe an Evo
what you can buy at the grocery store
has great waters but it's killed it
produces a million bottles per year this
is in the industry like nothing P
Lavinia would laugh about that number
right there pumping out a million
bottles per week
okay so for then it's just like what do
they want its kill this a very small
spring has been discovered by a
retirement couple in 2003 because they
wanted to build a smaller vacation house
in Denmark in a national reservoir and
the Danish government was saying yeah
you can build your house there but you
cannot bring a water pipeline through
our national reservoir and they thought
like okay back to the nature is nice but
like no water's a little bit too much
for us
oh yeah nature so they found the spring
send it over to a lab and the lab said
like wait a minute what's up with your
water there's something very unique
about it and they thought like oh [ __ ]
like maybe it's not good to water or
something when the lab is doing this
whole fuss about it they found the most
unique water ever been found
and nothing is super super small and
therefore I been to the spring for six
years ago it's like the spring house is
the size of this building here it's like
super small and when you think about
this and like you've seen these two
people they are smiling at you and like
yeah we found this cool water and we've
we wanted to share it with the world and
now they're bonding is skilled means
actually I spring in the Danish language
I love this kind of stories yeah laughs
and and every water has a little story
to it and I think this is really cool to
discover and then yeah sure you're
paying like I think you can find it at
erawan now for three or four dollars a
little bit more expensive but it's cool
it's a nice story of it and this is
nothing what I would drink on a daily
basis because hey I need to watch my
money and smell like everybody else
yeah so therefore I have big gallons of
ever hats at my places but when I'm
drinking on a daily basis or what I'm
going to a grocery store like Richie
that's my go to more each year our arrow
head is what you're saying spring when
I'm going on with a grocery store
because I love Fiji water it has a very
high silica content and silica makes
water extremely smooth that that's what
it is there see and I can tell you
something before this is confirmed I
thought I was crazy when I would think
about the idea that Fiji tasted smooth
to me yeah because that's it that would
be the first word that I would describe
it as and I you know I didn't I didn't
know any of this but it does to the
palate and you're about you're like this
why does this taste like silky smooth I
knew that already but a ministry has the
reason the course this water has one of
the highest silica content what ever
been found in silicon really liquor
silica
and that's a mineral it's a natural
coating middle I love it sheesh and how
do you say that in German again Cheers
post post post how do I do that thing
you're doing so when I when I compared
to your filtration systems they are both
are room temperature but it feels that
teach is more refreshing you know this
tastes like dog [ __ ]
it has more mineral content hundred
percent so the mineral content gives you
that that feel lanch give me a line
think about a soup without salt right
right your minerals it's like very bland
which I again and you want a little salt
to kick off the soup it's the same with
water no water with no mineral content
what it's like in your palate
flat and it makes you thirsty err yeah
like you just drank our house will that
was our house well I'm sorry like
apologize my shitty water it's totally
different so you can measure you can
measure the middle content by TDS total
dissolved solids and this waters a TDS F
of 222 le tap a lot of people will
surprise no between 200 and 400 TDS
purified water companies maximum of 40
TDS when you see like what's like one of
the voters people think they're getting
very smart when they're drinking that
water
um yes I Jennifer Anderson hmm
it's actually owned by Crowell corner
yes people don't know that a lot of
people drink that water but don't know
it but they are putting on their labels
and it electrolytes and everybody's like
a cool and I have a boy I want
electrolytes yeah la my friends have
some small electrolytes then wait
smart the smart water so that's a smart
order yeah that's that nonsense you buy
it Trader Joe's yeah yeah so they add
electrolytes to smart water adding
electrolytes but in very small amounts
and that is obviously cool thing that
people don't understand like well if I
edit electrolytes but they don't tell
you how many mg water has way more
electrolytes Wow
no more I mean Europe there's lots of
natural springs everywhere I feel like
that's a very euro thing like I know my
family we go to a place called Hades
which is like on the border whereas in
Austria and Hungary some Naturals but
like Europeans love their natural debt
we swim in it you drink it you bathe it
too very euro has something to do with
the culture in Europe because like yeah
just said bathing in it so spire is are
very famous all over Europe so people
went to the spyrius back in the day so
I'm still doing it for health benefits
and they want to make sure yes right
they want to treat themselves on water
embedding or even by drinking
therefore they understood the concept
that water is extremely important that
is actually the invention of bottled
water the first invention was the first
bottled water came from spy heiress s
medication because I invented right
people have went to the spire is to get
health again or like to have a health
product because the water has a lot of
minerals in it like how to magnesium all
this kind of minerals one is extremely
good for you when the people were too
sick to it this part people started to
bottle the waters and sent them over to
the sick people
Wow medication was invented but it water
loss and then Wow now these days a lot
of bottled water is more like hydration
just hydration right but back in the
days the history of all bottled waters
actually medication do you have a number
that you try to hit as far as
consumption per day do you tried it it
really depends what you're doing it
depends what kind of exercise you're
doing so over at me as a restaurant
person who walks around the rest all the
time I did BSN a 25 thousand steps she's
on Mother's Day obviously yeah is that
equal to again we're six seven miles or
me on something like this yeah yeah we
were slightly busy
I'm drink a lot of water but I'm trying
and this is the key as well drink the
whole time and not just think or I drink
a gun in the morning I drink a gallon in
the ya-ya
how do much it that doesn't work you
need to hydrate yourself all day I know
that is the key about modern water and
drinking water do not think you can hide
it yourself things can play I know the
water shimmers in the room as well and
he was able yes brings an gallons
injeel' hours yes pretty crazy and I
wanted to tell you a little story well
it's kind of like a sad story
yeah what happens here in California
somebody had a big game in the radio
how much water you can drink in one hour
here and that didn't work out well now
someone died right now so this person
were able to drink I think 12 bottles of
our leaders so 12 liters of water in one
hour and the whole was the whole game
was like hey try to drink so much water
in this hour and then Dali they don't
pee and winner we there was a we me
tenderize right yes three hours later
she died
Wow course Yukon something too much
water into your body your cells were
like literally like over cement of it
blowing up yeah completely drawn from
inside okay and that is very sad so
please guys yes I know
don't overthink it don't drink too much
water no there's really possibilities to
obviously not drink enough water
whatever definitely my parent that other
way along as well now I actually went to
a urologist a few years ago and I asked
him because like how much water should I
be drinking and he goes however much you
feel if you feel thirsty very often if
you say and I was like oh I thought
there's this rule but I have to have
eight ounces every two hour whatever
[ __ ] because that was the thing I
feel if you try to tell you the drink
item you have to have extra managers per
day or something like yeah that's when
you're sitting in an awfully and it's
stock you don't need so much water than
people obviously work on the street
right so it really depends what you're
doing people who are exercising
extremely having like jobs like
somewhere where they like move the whole
time needs way more water yeah then
people were sitting the whole day yes
we'll be normal throughout the key is
drink water that's the more important
thing do not start to drink sodas even
when you're thinking has made 90 percent
of water but let's say said all the
calories hidden when I read it question
now that brings us to our soda question
Lacroix Lacroix Lacroix I don't know how
you pronounce what is that water or as I
thought my husband seems to think it's
more water than soda
there are some waters like vitamin
waters for they even claiming those of
that this is water let's say that
vitamin water and soda sugar is everyone
yeah yeah no I didn't try to tell you
what about the zero calorie zero at like
Sevilla
why like are those water there obviously
there's there's a carbonation and they
would you like me to get why no they my
friend in combination to it yeah this
can happen does it sorta normal some
bottled water companies are doing this
for example monthly Springs are very
good water from America I love that
water it's a still it's a still spring
and they're adding combination to it the
same actually with San Pellegrino
century we know is a still water oh it
is and they're adding them and they're
adding the culmination to it you will
not find a sample of vino as a still
version on the planet because I'm
marking themselves as a sparkling water
right there
adding actually co2 to it Wow Wow so
that actually is your drinking water I
mean water water so it's water you Kelly
yeah but I talked a little bit about
yeah I think it's actually right no I
died this one yeah and I set the cool
storm maybe you can hear it when I'm
open the bottle deal yes still water but
still something happy right there
now I may not use the same glasses I
drank my Fijian because that would be
contaminating with water flavors that
right well the laterals right they could
be mineral residue that's right look at
what are you mix it but something you
look at anything is happening what and
when you look at this glass now over the
future glass before by the way this
conversation I'd be like those [ __ ] out
this is bad there's like a that's
already something going on here yeah and
there's bubbles they'll have any valid
it's still water so let's see what's
happening when I'm shake this bottle
because it's a still water and I'm not
just the only water Swami in America
I'm actually the David Copperfield of
waters I can do some magic with us as
well okay so I can turn in this intimate
ah let's see looks clear to you yeah
everything is good here we go right wow
that's a mineral bath dude now I feel
like I have seen that's crazy man anyway
like very slowly righty-o yeah it
disappears it's actually not the
minerals what is it it's not
combinations of Miller for you think I'd
come think about a silicon can it be no
fumbles no air officio to its carbon
oxygen oxygen
oxygen the water has a higher oxygen
content than all waters evidence found
in Denmark that's reason the lab was so
awful at this and said like what the
hell is going on here and they found out
is killed in what I said I spring in the
Danish language they found out that this
is a very very old spring water around
seven thousand twelve year old what we
have in this class and the cool thing
about this is there's a cold water holds
more oxygen than warm water does that's
reason sometimes New York in the
wintertime when you open the tap water
is sometimes cloudy as well and then
there's rain in hotels where that type
of thing happens and I go level not
drinking this [ __ ] and I it's going
erections but I'm a commercial media
types are exposed to extremely high
temperatures outside yeah yeah that's
the reason this water turns into this
very cloudy cloudy I'll take a brand
taste-wise any heads-up on what we're
going to experience as opposed to the I
always say as so McGee would be a bad
somebody when I without diving right
away what do you think what the taste
would be okay so I do think you should
discover if you see something and be
honest maybe you'll see like some people
have a hard time to divine feature
versus gilded so she is going to tears
oh my god no totally different totally
different especially the aftertaste the
aftertaste is a physics is very distinct
it smells like Europe it reminds me of
going to like a thermal bath or mineral
about whatever it with my parents that
Fiji still has a much more like when I
do it right after especially a much the
smoothness is still stands out as very
different it does have like that any or
whatever I don't know how to describe it
aftertaste right you'd like oh that's
enough there's are minerals yeah
definitely yeah the sodium quadrants way
higher the TDS is now 400
no it's almost a double of the mineral
content of hitching and interesting what
I think especially about the aftertaste
of skilled and it's like this slightly
earthy notes to it like think about a
mushroom or something like this that's
so many distinguished taste of its
killed I've been in China last year in a
big water tasting competition and I had
to taste 80 different waters blind
like say they gave me just the glasses
like this mmm
and then drink it and then I had to
quote like what I think about the water
they gave me is skilled and I will I
knew right away it says yeah you did
yeah I had 100% right away I gave 400%
100 points to is skill they're smart of
course for me it's one of the best
models I imitate real Wow I for me it's
just like there's so much characteristic
in it I love the idea about the oxygen
level as well here this water turns into
like the slightly milkiness to it it's
just mind-blowing water that's am and
then to be clear did you say this my
talent and can get it three or four
dollars yeah arrow arrow on or well then
Wow
let's get that is pretty cool I mean
that's a really cool thing I think it's
a very accessible price point pure and
experience in other words somebody wants
to try this like it's 3 or 4 bucks right
definitely did we're not talking about
like yeah I had waters for over $75
already what the most expensive water I
ever drunk it's hundred thousand dollars
come on
I did this was a dip you on 2 Chainz
Latin can go with Diplo into change yes
you can see it for G magazine the most
expensive ships are big did that come
out or why 100 grand see if you can see
it almost 8 million clicks already
module it's hilarious
either where's our rum yeah and actually
it's from California
yeah dawg so it's kind of travel to Rio
Rancho its way it's Beverly Hills night
or h2o ah silly
50 white diamonds on the caps that you
really so expand right Sally water
itself is very good as well and but
obviously this is more like a funny cool
yeah yes creator lightly crazy price
like diamond water
I know if you watch that reality show
the shot oh yeah like can you can you in
few does it matter if you in time use
water but dynamic or it's your boat yeah
when you believe in something that's a
very diplomatic answer from Marla I'm
like it's all about minerals for me show
me a little scientific fact that water
has metals dissolved yet of course it
comes from the disses rounds waters Tara
fascinating what's up with Helden with
what's that's our next one yeah our next
one so we need to save some glasses oh
yeah feel Elizabeth okay how do you say
water champion in German
the visage champion devatas champion
yeah so here is a sparkling water
and this is the official word of the
Queen huh she drinks this water all the
time this is the green water the Queen's
water and is it where's it from from
England a spa it is from England you
have to be a little careful because when
you're drinking too much chilled water
your arms have Mabel do like this I do
see a more distinguished now lava
bubbles and they're bigger they look
like they're big bubbles the modem this
bubbles and again like in the beginning
everybody watched me looking at the
glass and now you guys doing this as
well because you can already see okay
obviously we're talking here about a
carbonated water and the Palash what I
would say to it right now it's pretty
big interesting fact about this mod is
that the carbonation that was actually
very low but it's just like some big
bubbles involved in that water but it's
not like this progressive like maybe I
gave ourselves in Germany or something
we know what has like tons of fun yeah I
hate tons of bubbles
this is like gently Spock yeah well
she's a queen man she is cheers whoops
whoops I love it
see it to me this is so European to
American bottled waters I mean the
sparkling waters never taste this subtle
and the cool thing about this is a
longer I am telling you right away as
well what's actually in here and this is
kind of sad that mostly the purified
water companies especially again they
don't tell you at all what they added
right Kiev says right away magnesium
content 1.7 calcium 97 sodium 7.7
chlorine 16 fluoride 8 to 12 degrees to
0.02 so super low what it should be in
water because flood is not really
something what you want to want to drink
the whole time and total subsolid 312 so
they're adding the time right away
honestly I think the biggest iOpener at
least for me and I think I imagine for
people listening is the idea that
reading that there's things in your
water it doesn't equal automatically or
in any way necessarily bad thing because
I think every one of us probably who
does loader although that's bad yeah he
wants the mineral side
middles now for pure cause of his
creative silliness I would drink a lot
more sparkling water if it weren't for
the saltiness the sodium content I find
that a lot of them are very salty and I
you can tell you'll hear it yes it will
be tough for you guys okay kiddos or
salty water audio so would you consider
it so is this a nice option if you're
going to go for sparkling water would
you say I think you'll know we're moving
yeah but I love film we're playing the
sodium content is very low if you had a
salty the bubbles are very tiny and like
that not like this progressive in your
palate despite can easily shut down this
bottle and it's not like that you're
like yeah yeah feeling like blowing up
right away now can I ask you how you
have a water menu that you offer yeah I
feel like we go to a lot of nice
restaurants and travel a lot and still
even in high-end restaurants I get the
question
tap still or sparkling in other words
there's no other is the option thing
going to be developing more you think
restaurants I really hope so and I think
the first concept is that people need to
understand that they should drink more
water and finally in America butters
what is the most consumed product now
and so they're not anymore so this is
not amazing since to thank guy bottled
water is a number one consumer product
Wow and I love this I love to hear this
so obviously the Americans understand
that sort of might be not the best
choice to drink and sure enough on yes
well now the next step is to understand
that water is not just water yeah and
that there are big quality or
differences and again some waters are
coming from municipal source it's
actually nothing up in your tap water so
just in tap and here's the money yeah or
other water's coming from the different
regions of the world and therefore they
taste differently that's all come on I'm
an example on my mind so let's see this
is this a sparkling water about ever
sparking water Vichy Catalan we call and
it's like the arrowhead of Spain this is
a number one consumed sparkling water
and Spain but I spent on Conan O'Brien
as well for 12 years ago nacho I did the
water tasting with him and he spit out
that water really yep it was like what
the hell is going on here so he didn't
believe me that this is coming from
nature Wow deer don't I add a p-value
really really yeah he thought I'd put
like an
spending and this is um this is produced
in Spain other words it hundred miles
applause from Barcelona it's going to
spring okay so it's a spring it's a
spring water hundred percent spring
water natural occurring comes right up a
hundred forty degrees Farenheit was a
super hot spring
what rise up the water so we had a very
cold spring it's Gilda there's now a
very hot spring Vichy Camelot okay so
yeah way more progressive than in the
Hilton they look at Hillside no they are
almost no bubbles anymore is like
there's really something going on okay
mm-hmm oh my goodness
dude that is like an explosion of
saltiness for yo it are very bitter at
the end very salty
I also by the way what quality is it
because now I can I can take me back now
that I've had Stillwater in traveling
that has some of that taste because that
is that the sodium that it's the sodium
so sort of the first thing you can you
can get how did the dragon with a soul
really strong and this is right away
we're talking about over a thousand
milligrams so salty yeah it's crazy the
TBS level is mind-blowing 3050 what it
has more electrolytes in a Gatorade
going on with doin what's wrong with it
the reason they're so hydrated maybe
it's mainly I said the Spanish people
that's reason they lost this water it's
super hot outside in Spain like in LA
yeah so you're smelling all the time
yeah and when you're sweaty losing
minerals yeah that's pretty much because
that's the reason your spread of salty
so when you compare a vision column and
drink this all the time you're getting
all your minerals back yeah well the
thing is what you cannot do and a lot of
people always say like oh just waddled
water and then you'll be fine that
doesn't work as well because we all know
around two days it's makes you lose
dehydrate and then you will die after
two or three days and after two or three
weeks you will die because you didn't
have any food yeah so your body the most
minerals what your body needs comes from
food because in food there's way more
minerals actually than bottled water ice
but bottled water is a cool thing
because the minerals are already
dissolved as water so it's very easy to
access this for your body demands
because you don't need really to process
it and let's think about
alkaline water
everybody talks about our talent crying
so important America Line's
that's a very it's also very trendy
right now it's very trendy yeah it needs
to be balanced and some people saying I
can unbought er you can balance out your
body with us because your body is acidic
because you're eating so much acidic
food and with an alkaline water you can
balance out your your body pH and then
you are healthy completely [ __ ] I
really do not believe in that literally
correct the course when you drink water
what we just it it goes into your
stomach so your stomach is up with fluid
and the a máquina and the senate float
an extremely acidic yeah so water will
turn like this acidic Oh God that whole
idea about or you can balance out
something with a pH level is completely
not nonsense is your body your body's
highly is that your stomach it has to
break down that food whatever this whole
idea about alkaline water do not have
believed in this whole claim by the way
I can't believe we haven't put this
together yet with Martin here do you
know this clip are you I want to
breastfeed you wash I was shocked why
it's a German man he also is there any
sheesh but he's provided us in a
different way I wanted you to know what
kind of show you were on like we've
mislaid yeah I know I don't leave a
radio ok and when the bunnies had this
water in their mouth they also like Oh
taste like deep yeah really like you
like okay yeah no image is not just 10
times worse than that really
hahahaha are going be we're going on
again why are we are okay no what comes
out so excited even thing justice the
other okay crazy one oh yes I'd that
blew my mind matter how this start of a
little taste okay Wow
let me ask you one question before we
move on so your palate I mean you have
to keep it so sensitive
how do you maintain your palate flavor
your I don't you have liquor no hard
liquor no cane cocktails I cannot study
cocktail and I learn for my analogy
other than I don't like cocktails yeah I
don't drink hard liquor at all I'll
of wine and sparkling wines this is like
what I'm thinking when I'm like two
boosts up how about coffee no coffee
what is that for your palate for just I
don't like the taste it's too bitter for
me maybe every coffee I tasted so far
always just bitter and I think my palate
is just like involved over so many years
now to drink with so much water that my
pail is extremely sensitive how on a
stone will you grab from the fridge a
vivia and ilaqua thank you the cool
thing as well is about drinking water
and I had this with the second I had a
videos on YouTube as well with a girl
from Zagat and we're tasting different
water huh and she never drinks too much
water and you see in the end of the
video she's she feels like wasted she
didn't had any alcohol but she feels
like she started so tickling and like
she and it was like I have drunk and
she's like I don't know but I feel like
a little camping up here at sea and I
think it was like she might be as a
person who doesn't drink so much water
all the time then I exposed her to so
much water into extremely high mineral
content water that her body was like
really reacting to it it seemed like she
was like honest attitudes are normal
sound are anything and as you can see it
on YouTube it's kind of it's kind of
funny if you really sit like in the
camera thing actually really drunk yeah
yeah and water has an impact on your
body absolutely since crater is cool we
brought this in because this is a
Christina made a good point
like what what is going on with these I
know that Lacroix exists I have to say I
never had it before it's so funny I know
they're bad sodium free yeah and the CBO
one they're the one that he just put on
that table
it has it's the content on it as well
the funny thing is here they don't tell
you where this water is actually coming
from that's always our EPS like always
fully across ingredients Calvin well the
Lacroix natural brand is in Wisconsin
and I assume that they they make and
bottle and everything there sure are you
sure it's from Wisconsin yeah that's why
that's the whole argument alliance all
Detroit funny bubble of Warren Michigan
is here this distribution distribution
right but I don't tell you where the
spring is located all let's see so we
don't know this is
bring water or purified water oh my god
so we have no clue guy now we like this
beverage it's an alternative to soda we
don't drink sugar so extreme your shield
and the problem is when you know when
you're shutting something down I know
it's like refreshing but you cannot
really taste anything anymore because
when you're shutting down a beverage in
general like even wines extremely the
taste aromas are like disappearing a
little bit yeah so let's see we should
bring this on a little temperature too
so there's definitely a smell right away
yeah it's like it's like a blueberry
fruity smell to it it tastes extremely
sweet hmm
extremely sweet it has very tiny bubbles
you cannot taste water from this right
corner so it's like there's there's
artificials and this is so many
artificial flavors you can see it as
well huh like it's clear so it's water
yeah but obviously they are adding some
artificial flavors and they said this is
highly processed food that's not honest
this is nothing else than highly
processed food so this is stuff what you
like when you like the Big Mac for
McDonald's it's might be the water to go
oh my god oh and look there look at
their website where does the water
originate American brand using water
source from the u.s. ratified Kerala
days when they sing this this means it's
actually tap water look at this I don't
want to say that it's using a triple
filtration system here we go
yep yep it's crap yeah it's stripped of
any mineral design what I thought yeah
now try this vivia because my husband's
convinced that he's drinking water when
he's drinking Xena is gonna be even
sweeter
Wow sorry he thinks it is over if you
think I know a little sweetness okay
there's no artificial sweeteners no yeah
you oughta free sweetness but no address
on flavor
didn't that doesn't say that it doesn't
say that yeah
um now I mean Lacroix was sweet to him
oh very sweet this is another one
curious you see what happened all that
great oxygen looking like I saw it
already that looks like a soda what are
you pouring this now
yeah it's naturally flavored ice open it
right now it makes stronger and you're
gonna feel better
wha-ha-ha-ha-ha
it's like dr. pepper yeah that's like
the smell it's like Doc sherry I think
yeah large area like sure but it's
natural it's all natural
well they say natural flavors that no
artificial stuff in it right I apologize
yeah I'm saying this on camera and
radial but too good it's a good review
so I'm not you know Jesus oh I agree I
agree Kanye loves it will give you a
case on the way I show so what Pepsi
crystal there was a single yeah 50 no
throws yeah it's like I need play some
it's gonna clean your power or something
else I wish something my husband
considers this drinking water do you
know that when he drinks this he goes
it's like drinking water this is nothing
to do with Walter Kaiser what is it what
is emoted I mean I know you don't know
love it that's the same what icing Pepsi
crystal was yes it crystal was a coke
with no color this looks like a soda
with no color for me very much what it
is here's why people are it's that it's
the there's no artificial Addison
there's no sugar
so people are drinking this because it's
become a popular beverage because it's
like you're having a soda experience but
you're not getting that glucose spike
you know I got it I got it disgusting
now I don't like them I don't drink them
but all we see there's like artificial
sweetener on yeah speaking about
obviously they need to do something with
something to to put some I think it's
religiously Jesus blesses it or someone
and it has been there whatever it's in
there but I know okay
skywriting let's move it along
um he spent that how hilarious so I feel
it's like we should call on is like a
beautiful moment with no to it yeah I
know
and then so far there's one two three
four five bottles that I've never even
heard of that's what's so cool and it's
two more that we haven't yet so we have
Roy as a next one from Pennsylvania okay
now yeah my cousins Aurelio thank you
are these by the way available at patina
are these or some of them Vichy
available hoodies available features
available and is skilled as available
okay Roy you guys are the only people in
the whole United States who have a
bottle like since like ah what what
nobody else has Roy oh this is so a guy
yeah I know the the owner very well here
owns a hotel in Slovenia and they found
off the spring is extremely old I have
to be a little careful actually as well
you should see it because it looks like
own okay yeah when I'm open this is
really like something going on oh yeah
there's salt collected at the brought
you can see and you know this one is
like this Wow like I notice how its
natural II guess it's natural it's
wonderful you can actually see the
flakes the minerals at the bottom and it
looks like a soda as well when I'm
pouring it yeah
whoa that's cool yeah you can see like
wow residues snow right down here what
it's not so don't worry guys it's all
good all natural hundred percent it's
likely via just like the yeah II like it
about it like what's happening here yeah
what is going on now is it that the
mineral level is so high that that's
what the flakes are yes but it's still
safe to drink yes so different it's from
a spring I just said nice she's yours Oh
Cheers
oh here we go I guess a goodra
oh no it just as beautiful as German oh
my god mmm oh my goodness I love this
you know when I go to Hungary I feel
like this is the kind of stuff that when
you ask for sparkling this is what you
get you get this actually because it is
like distinctly the the high sodium
feels to me European
yeah but there's something else in that
water yeah not just the sodium there are
very metallic taste to it mm-hmm
and this water has the highest hello
magnesium content whatever been found in
a spring water Wow
what do you think the TDS level
Assessors maybe can let me recap a
little bit Fuji 222 TDS yeah it's Gilder
was far no tedious here we went back to
312 BC 3063 now what is right now that
5000 won yes I sell the place is right
here well yeah I would go even higher 7
because of I mean look how active that
water is the European one huh yeah hey
that's my employ yeah yeah raising but
this is again now not for hydration
anymore so Roy is a water and they even
marketing like this it's not like a
water you will drink on a daily basis
because it's so loaded with metals and
this is so heavy in your palate as well
it's like you cannot drink we do a lot
of this I was going to say when as a
whole point doesn't it don't these
levels affect how you're tasting food
the other words well everything yeah
when you're drinking a Roy and you try
to taste like food right next to it
forget it
the food will be tasteless company
because this water has so overwhelmed
you know it's all events you cool thing
about Roy is just put a little drops
into our oyster
I mean like noise is really amazing and
taste something really if heavy change
noise are feeling so that's pretty cool
that's amazed how water like for a
dietary restriction that's like
recording it in Europe healthy waters
yeah in Germany they would have a
medication label on it they would yes
easily is considered to be a health
water well I have different regulations
in Germany and this is I think where the
American market really needs to step up
their game a little bit when it comes to
bottled water the regulations are very
strict when it comes to bottled water
and Germany and the labeling as well Eva
and the government is saying like buy
some waters there's a brand from Korres
called Bond axon and bollocks are
spelled in a regular basic la aqu a yeah
Oxfam and they said like the German
government no wait a minute that's like
purified water born are Cummings good
water you cannot label this Wow so they
misspelled actual AQA on purpose that
they can label Bond aqua Wow
the regulations are very strict now but
I think it's good I want it for the
person listening or watching this how
can they this is like an obviously
intriguing topic learn more like is it
should I go to your site like what do
you reckon you can go to my site you can
you can come to patina obviously yeah I
know what to tell what happens that on a
daily basis and we have this beautiful
water menu when I brought a smile and
over here so this is the patina water
menu we have 20 different mineral waters
and every water has like two pages and
you can literally like see where it is
profile of that water a story of the
water the pds conveyed and actually
what's in there and then a price so and
this goes like 220 different waters what
we are offering right now this is
incredible Dinah Lee is coming up in
July we will have a water tasting based
on our based on our Dinah lay menu as
well so three different waters pair to
your dishes wait how much is the ROI the
slovenian yeah this is a tricky part so
Roy you kind of excess you in America
but retail will be around $25 okay I'm
doing what is this last one here that we
see that some hunger looks like it - I
read this along that's my favorite oh so
is there like hatred and contempt and
well how they put that in a lot less
that would be amazing
maybe should we should all get a new
glass yeah okay okay this is this is a
special line getting very special again
thank you thank you sir I like the Roy I
really like this Roy is actually pretty
cool I have this sometimes in water
tastings as well what I do and people
always stick to Roy yeah they always
like that's a really cool water I
looking it's so unique it's so yes but
they're saying like I really love that
water it's a it's been an eye also like
the level of the bubbliness
I like the sodium content I feel like no
no so it got a lot of pizzazz yeah the
Queen likes a duller sparkling water or
interesting English let's see the
Hungarian this is a still water again
again
so we're going but it has little little
middle content you okay called Mira yeah
hungaria and let's just set stasis I
guess you get to choose that's all about
it them pulse again Tuesday okay let's
see mm-hmm that is whoa horrible that is
just terrible
what is going on I even think that as
well that is Etta so Walter or saltwater
no I expect that is garbage
what is that terrible smell of sulfur
don't you want some zvf re-ask you want
to be again says seven thousand five
hundred milligrams of sulphur let me see
that connects you tomorrow where is
there my bottled water like guys PDF so
before you see the ball TDS level PBS
level though is high yeah really it's in
the thousands it's got it what 8,000
8,000 higher 10 on the 16 18 now hideous
its but but in Hungary we have a lot of
Springs and there's a lot I'm sorry meal
a convenience-store how long get bottled
water like you're just visiting you grab
that off the shelf now that's a linear
and you're getting out of take you [ __ ]
so that's the reason again guys water is
not just water water has taste and even
here I know a lot of purified waters
again filling everything out of there
they creating shining voice that
everybody sings ours all tastes the same
yeah they all taste the same
oh you see now here there's sort of what
I brought something realize holy [ __ ]
yeah what has taste
I could write somebody on Kota yeh
tomasa I've never seen this one on a
[ __ ] that looks awesome
was disgusting is not your jr. this is
so much upsetting water is terrible I
mean and when I go to when I'm in
Budapest I always order a Schwinn DS
which is sparkling water and they
definitely don't bring that [ __ ] they
bring their office they bring stuff
similar to I would say the Spanish one
but I want to like that's a Hungarian
look at you to recap table one of the
things - leg two basic like advanced
yourself and then a ch4 spring water
glacier water or what correct mineral
water mineral
says on the bottle and it's this is
really the key guys always when you're
going to the grocery store and do it
with your kids do it with your family
it's kind of yeah yeah like buy several
bottles of water but make sure they are
all coming from a natural resource yeah
because then they will taste differently
then have them side by side do not show
them down at them side by side in
different classes and really taste them
through and then sudden you will realize
holy [ __ ] water has taste yeah yeah it's
from Earth I mean think about it it's
how many another earth we should be
thankful that we can drink all this kind
of cool different waters that we have
access to clean water we're going to get
bloom and some of that and let's face it
as well there are millions of people who
don't have access to clean water their
topic for me as well some water summary
because everybody knows I have like so
many different cool waters and some
people think I'm the most hydrated
personal planet but they are yeah
millions of people are millions of
people who don't have access and I think
we should all honored that we have
access to clean water and we should help
people who don't have access so yeah
whatever like for example I'm supporting
the Matt Damon foundation and I'm trying
to raise money all the time to to help
other country is that is that his water
org
yes or to the Matt Damon thinking I
could be big on that right like and I
think it's a great thing what he's doing
there and I'm supporting them even on
the home page there's a link that you
can spend some money and and I think
it's a good thing to do yeah so super
cool this was the most mind-blowing
thing I you know you think it but you
don't think about water no I mean I mean
I don't I just consumed it that to me
yeah this was out in California we had
for the last five years a big drought
finally yeah we are out of the drought
right but I think that doesn't mean we
can waste water again right so this is
the point as well what I like to do with
my water menu I want to give water a
value that people understand hey there's
a bit more than than just water yeah and
maybe I could start to rethink my use of
water as well and maybe when I'm washing
my teeth don't have the tab open the
whole time just close it even California
storm a drought right now
yes I still we need to save water
because the summer is coming trust me in
two years we are back on surrounds very
big drought problem again we have to
save water for the future generations
and therefore let's all drink enough
water that's the key guys do not drink
sodas drink enough water but please be
considered as well what you're doing
with water
yeah very good Martin Reesa Reesa Reesa
Reesa like a giant personal journey
that's kind of really I don't know
we see our IESE oh is it that way RI es
yeah anyway a web site is a Martin -
reset right mm-hmm comm you can go to
patina in downtown Los Angeles and
actually see Martin in the flesh and
experience the water menu and actually
you know I think this is really cool
try out different waters and and and see
if you guys can experience them what we
did here today it's a very very
eye-opening you can take a class from
Martin he can that's what I'm saying you
can fighting Eliza Chino yeah call me up
shoot me an email
I'm always happy to hydrate people oh my
gosh thank you so thank you so much for
coming on I know there was cool very
cool this is a h2 flow signing off and
yeah I got a I got a song for us so let
me see what he does anything not the
water jamming keine vas the choices
initiative our search engine is Miss
Nestor Miss Nestor
yeah dare 9
that's not disease specialist [ __ ]
guys see on the next one
all right here we go first I'm going
over the new bridge
oh my god totally lame we played like
money like 20 lead only when green only
23 only when he grows when clean only
[Music]